well we've been taking a look at the
colorado river system which
brings water to millions of people in
the west including to us right here in
las vegas so water levels at lake mead
they keep
dropping the federal government's
expected to declare its first ever
tier one shortage soon chip yost from
our sister station in los angeles
visited lake mead recently to see what
that means for the region
here at lake mead in nevada the water
has slowly
but surely been disappearing to give you
an idea how much
things have changed right now where i'm
standing is a place
i wouldn't have been able to stand not
so long ago
probably maybe 10 years ago that you'd
be
under water completely right where we're
standing right now danny now
tracy steven of southern california has
been boating here with his family
for decades when you look at some of
these surrounding
mountains and hills and stuff the water
was up where where the brown part is
and now it's it's down and we've watched
it come down
over the last 10 15 years it just keeps
going down and down and down and
now it's almost impossible to launch as
we previously reported lake mead is also
the reservoir for the hoover dam
and to see just how much it's gone down
look at this picture from november of
2000
paying particular attention to these
intake towers
and compare that to our visit in june of
this year
it's a scary picture for the multiple
states
who rely on lake mead and the colorado
river system
of which it's a part of for water for us
lake mead is particularly important in
california
devenu padia is the chief operating
officer of the metropolitan water
district
the largest treated drinking water
provider in the united states
the district provides water to about 19
million
southern californians in six different
counties
much of that water is delivered by the
colorado river
aqueduct when you look at kind of an
average over the last 10 years the
colorado river provides about 25 percent
of the water that's used in southern
california places like las vegas phoenix
and tucson
also get water from the river but soon
they may not be getting as much we're at
the point where
some serious decisions will likely need
to be made
doug hendricks is with the u.s bureau of
reclamation
he says in august the record low water
levels in lake mead are expected to
trigger
the bureau's first ever declaration of a
tier one water shortage
on the system that would mean cutbacks
starting next year
and the amount of colorado river water
sent to nevada
and arizona states that have already
seen reductions in their share
of the river's water mexico would also
get less
but thanks to senior water rights and
other agreements
california's share of water from the
colorado
won't be cut just yet but if the trend
continues
california could be next
at lake mead near the nevada arizona
border i'm chip yost
8 news now